let's go and I won't reject nation Greg
he'll be here day three of watching a
stranger thing season two so I'm still
sick my ears still ringing like a mother
F word finally made it to the last
episode
you
so with the show concluding you know I
got a couple of predictions right I feel
like the situation Bob is probably a
situation a lot of people were probably
guessing that he would die I was really
proud of myself in my play-by-play on
how a lot of things turned out on that
situation that was I did a pretty good
job there the one thing I really thought
of how it would end would be Jonathan
and Nancy not getting together and then
she goes back with Steve but it didn't
turn out that way so show proved me
wrong there a good job show I really
don't get the point of red ranger being
in this show I don't don't really get
the point of max other than serving as
another love interest for Lucas or have
the love triangle thing kind of reminded
me of it just a little bit some really
big pros in love with what they did with
the season was the involvement of Steve
you know Steve as a character I really
didn't like in the first season as the
show intended for a good portion of it
and then in this season he's kind of
become one of my favorite characters I
think I think it's a pretty soft finale
for what this season is and what the
story of the season is in terms of the
entirety of this season if I don't
compare it to season one I still think
it's pretty good I like the way it built
episode seven is something I've heard
that people complain a lot about with
the spin-off pilot thingy I didn't ruin
this season for me at all I still really
enjoyed it but there's something so even
when they all succeed in the end I
didn't feel that full like victory
feeling or accomplished resolution type
of feeling that I was hoping I would
feel there seems to be like a lack of
impact I mean it was sweating the thing
out of will you know just put him in a
sauna untie him - no it's not those kind
of week I guess there's nothing else
like I'm not imaginative enough right
now to come up with something cool or
they could have done one thing I loved
about stranger things is there are
problem solving and really having to
take down a hard obstacle scenarios and
in this scenario it seems like a pretty
easy thing to have you know got in this
thing out of will this thing that's been
causing so much trouble is all he has to
do is sweat it out it's a tough process
for him to endure it's painful for him
to endure sure it's not hard for the
other characters to really work with all
the guy do is keep the guy tied down and
put him in a hot-ass room you're pretty
sick where is the first season left off
in a way where it felt like this chapter
was concluding but there's still room
for more
I kind of feel like this show could end
here I know it's not going to it's
definitely not going to I just think
that it ends in a way where it could
pretty much end right here with the nice
little tease at the upside down is still
around in case they want to do more I
like how it ends with 11 still being
around because for a second there was
she was closing in I thought that she
was she might actually go away again
which kind of would annoyed me so I'm
glad that she's still around I'm
interested to see what they'll do with
season 3 is loving it eventually we go
in a regular school with these guys is
11 sister gonna come into this season or
they can actually do that spin-off and I
don't know how people felt about the
demo Gorgons having that kind of aliens
vibe where instead of one there's a
bunch of them now they're younger so
they're not all as strong cuz they're
younger but they're scary because
they're in large quantity so I don't
know how audiences have been responding
to that I thought it was a pretty cool
touch actually I like that addition but
next time around I want to see more new
things you know I like the whole
quantity touch it does pay tribute to
aliens in that retrospect I still want
to see more new creatures this time
around and get to know more new things
and I think with this season I guess why
if I I'm gonna compare it to season 1 I
guess but I don't feel like it's as
tightly woven the first season had a
pretty specific focus it was like
detailed and there was a lot of stories
going on and a but it all centered
around one thing which is will is
missing and everyone has one central
goal which is to find will and here
there's kind of a bunch of different
stories going on and they're all in
their own directions that are all kind
of linked to everything that's happened
in season one and then to the upside
down and yadda yadda yadda but they're
all a bunch of separate stories that are
not have this one unifying circle to it
throughout by the time they all come
together I think by episode 8 yeah by
episode 8 it started feeling like a
little bit rushed on concluding things
just a little bit what's not to a point
where it's a disappointment it's just a
little feeling I have whatever says my
feelings to worry about man my ear is so
ringing so loud I just felt a little
over the place of course it all does
come together in the end I just didn't
feel as tightly woven or a strongly
knitted I don't know what the correct
analogy or phrase is here to use but I
hope you guys get what I'm trying to say
right now I guess another missing
feeling to me was the impact
of the group of kids there was will and
Mike who were kind of separate from the
the rest of the game one theme it kept
toying with in this season which I
appreciate is you know how friends don't
lie and everyone in this season was like
a lot of people are lying to each other
in this season and especially with the
Maine boys and I kind of didn't feel
that's you know wouldn't season one ends
you like love those boys and you feel
like they are the the centerpiece and
the integral part to what makes this
show so strong by the time this ended
appreciated 11 and I appreciate it Steve
and I thought the adults did a lot more
work the feeling of the kids felt way
more like supporting characters this
time around as opposed to leading the
series which is an element I kind of
feel like I missed out on a bit and also
this is just my first time watching this
so I feel like this might be one of
those seasons that will grow on me over
time this is my initial impressions I've
yet to hear what everyone else is saying
about the show I did like it overall I
would say I really enjoyed the hell out
of it there's some great suspenseful
moments there are moments that really
had me moved even though there's some
characters would have liked to have
spent a little bit more time with her
had evolved a little bit more in the
show I still enjoyed hanging out with
everyone here
I like the inclusion of Bob there's a
few things here that I didn't really
like or that I didn't feel it was a
strong but overall I would still say it
was a damn good season and I'm excited
for season three and I can't wait to go
to bed hey you guys can subscribe to the
reel rejects please click that
notification bell while you're at it go
check out our patreon become a patronage
act today because everything over there
is really helping keep this channel
alive and plus there's some awesome
reward tiers for you guys as well